sie ist die jüngste Parteivorsitzende
Deutschlands und vielleicht die mit den
höchsten Ansprüchen Ricarda lang hat
versprochen grüne Ziele in der Regierung
umzusetzen verteidigen muss sie jetzt
lauter Tabubrüche welche ideale werfen
die Grünen in der Krise nicht über Bord
das frage ich heute die co-vorsitzenden
der Partei hier in Düsseldorf herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo Frau lang hallo guten Tag schön
sie haben rein zu Treffen herzlich
willkommen beim ZDF sommerinterview wir
treffen Sie hier nicht in ihrer
politischen Heimat in Baden-Württemberg
sondern sie sind auf Sommertour als
Parteivorsitzende deswegen treffen wir
uns in Düsseldorf genau ich hätte sie
auch gerne meinen Wahlkreis eingeladen
aber gerade sind wir tatsächlich in ganz
Deutschland auch in Norwegen unterwegs
zum Thema Klimaschutz hier in Düsseldorf
sind sie aus GRÜNER Sicht natürlich an
der ganz guten Stelle denn da regieren
die Grünen mit allerdings muss man dazu
sagen nicht in einer Ampel sondern
Schwarz-Grün das ist eine ganz andere
politische Farbe als im Bund ist das so
ein bisschen der Beleg dafür dass es
ihnen eigentlich egal ist in welcher
politischen Ausrichtung sie regieren
Hauptsache regieren nein ich glaube es
bewegt dafür dass wir in verschiedenen
Konstellationen grüne Ziele durchsetzen
können das zeigen wir gerade wenn wir
brot-rot-grün in Berlin regieren wenn
wir Schwarz-Grün hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen regieren und in der
Ampel im Bund überall ist grün erkennbar
wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien an Klimaschutz
aber auch an Gerechtigkeit denke und ich
glaube das war in den letzten Jahren
tatsächlich Stärke der Grünen Partei die
Frage ist ja was sind grüne Ziele wenn
sie regieren wenn wir mal
Baden-Württemberg schauen da regiert
schon ziemlich lange ein grüner nämlich
Winfried Kretschmann und den erkennt man
manchmal als grünen gar nicht mehr so
richtig wieder der hat einmal die
Kaufprämie für Autos mit Verbrennermotor
gefordert der sagt jetzt ach komm lasst
die AKW doch ein bisschen länger am Netz
ist das die Art wie grüne regieren wenn
sie dann zu lange regieren also die
zweite Aussage habe ich schon gar nicht
mitbekommen sondern hat sich ja diese
Woche da auch sehr klar positioniert
aber ich glaube was man sieht in
Baden-Württemberg wo ich ja auch
herkomme ist dass man es hinbekommen hat
in einem sehr industriell geprägten auch
eher konservativen Land Klimaschutz
gesamtgesellschaftlich mehrheitsfähig zu
machen den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien bei mir im Wahlkreis sehr sehr
schwarz geprägt jetzt endlich
voranzubringen und ich glaube das zeigt
vor allem grünes regieren wirkt sie
sagen grünes regieren und Grüne
Grundsätze beißen sich nicht darüber
würde ich gerne gleich noch ein bisschen
weiter mit ihnen reden das machen wir
drüben bei unserem Set sehr gerne
bitteschön
[Musik]
voll lange wir sind gerade mittendrin in
einer hitzigen gesellschaftlichen
Debatte über die Energiepolitik in
Krisenzeiten und ihr Koalitionspartner
Christian Lindner hat heute noch einmal
gesagt notfalls müssten Atomkraftwerke
bis 2024 am Netz bleiben wann geben sie
eigentlich die Gegenwehr für eine
Verlängerung auf das was Christian
Wiedner da will ist nichts anderes als
der Wiedereinstieg in die Atomkraft und
das wird es mit uns auf jeden Fall nicht
geben ich finde manchmal dass wir eine
etwas unernsthaftigkeiten dieser Debatte
haben dafür dass wir immer noch über
eine hochrisikotechnologie sprechen
viele Menschen machen sich Sorgen mit
Blick auf Winter und mit Blick auf den
Herbst was die Gasversorgung was die
Energieversorgung angeht und gerade weil
diese Sorgen da sind sind wir es glaube
ich verpflichtet den Menschen Antworten
zu geben die auch tatsächlich zum
Problem passen also das zu tun was
wirklich hilft aber das zu lassen was
eigentlich nicht möglich hilft sie sagen
jetzt das ist eine un ernsthafte Debatte
allerdings glaube ich dass die Menschen
schon mit großem Ernst darauf schauen es
gibt jetzt eine neue Umfrage von Insa
gerade ergeben hat dass 70 Prozent der
Befragten tatsächlich für eine
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten sind und
tatsächlich sogar die Mehrheit der
Grünen Wähler nämlich 54% auch sagen in
dieser Notsituation muss man darüber
reden und es wäre gut wenn sie länger am
Netz bleiben würden können Sie das
einfach ignorieren
ignorieren gar nichts haben wir setzen
uns ja dauerhaft mit der aktuellen
Situation heraus aber gerade weil eben
viele Menschen sich Sorgen machen um den
Herbst und Winter und ich kann das gut
verstehen über die steigenden Preis aber
vor allem auch wirklich um die Frage ist
die Versorgung gewährleistet ist es ja
so wichtig dass wir nicht ein Pflaster
nehmen was gar nicht auf die Wunde passt
weil es vielleicht angenehme oder
einfacher ist also Pflaster ist wirklich
passt was Energie sparen wäre wenn eine
gasmangelage haben und es ist so dass
die Gaskraftwerke in Deutschland nur zu
einem sehr kleinen Teil in der
Verstromung eingesetzt werden und da nur
zu einem winzigen Teil durch die
Atomkraft ersetzt werden könnte wer mein
Wärmeproblem kein Stromproblem und wenn
man sie versuchen würde zu setzen wenn
wir da unter einem Prozent das steht
starken Risiken entgegen da komme bei
einer riesigen nutzenabwägung dazu dass
das nicht der richtige Weg ist wenn Sie
das sagen dann schauen sie aber
natürlich jetzt nur auf den kommenden
Winter aus ihrer eigenen Partei gibt es
auch Stimmen die da etwas anders sagen
Ralf Füchs altgedienter grüner hat
darauf hingewiesen es kann sehr wohl
sehr schnell eine stromkrise werden wenn
sie es zum Beispiel ernst meinen mit der
E-Mobilität oder wenn im Winter die
Menschen anfangen mit mit Elektrizität
zu heizen also haben sie doch dann ein
Stromproblem und müssten dann
nachsteuern warum nicht jetzt schon
sagen für den Notfall muss das mit AKW
gehen weil wir hier immer noch von
großen Risiken sprechen immer schauen
müssen einen Nutzen kostenabwägung was
macht tatsächlich Sinn und wir schauen
uns ja die aktuelle Situation immer an
wir haben jetzt gerade eine gasmangelage
da gasmangelage macht ja turmkraft
keinen Sinn wir haben nach dem jetzigen
Berechnungen wir prüfen das Jahr seit
Monaten das BMW Card das
Wirtschaftsministerium hat immer wieder
verschiedene Tests gemacht haben wir
keine strohmangellage mit Blick auf den
Herbst mit Blick auf den Winter wir
machen jetzt noch mal es gab bisher
einen Stresstest schon im März wir
rechnen noch mal nach und natürlich
Schaden uns das an das Ergebnis an und
werden anhand des Ergebnis entscheiden
also kann es sein dass sie dann sagen
AKW müssen länger im Netz bleiben wir
werden uns dann das Ergebnis anschauen
das ist ja erstmal die Reihenfolge wenn
ich ein Test mache erstmal teste ich
dann schaue ich mir das Ergebnis an was
es nicht geben wird ist ein
Wiedereinstieg aber wir wollen es jetzt
nicht sagen ich würde gerne noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass es keine rein
innerdeutsche Debatte ist sondern das
aus Europa mittlerweile auch Stimmen
kommen aus den Nachbarländern die sagen
welche Art von Solidarität ist das
eigentlich wenn Deutschland nicht an
allen Stellen Gas spart auch bei der
Verstromung jetzt weil sie gerade darauf
beharren wollen dass die AKW nicht zu
lange am Netz bleiben wo ist da die
Solidarität die die Grünen auch immer
eingefordert haben aber da müssen wir
uns doch der Debatte ich glaube es ist
wirklich wichtig hier präzise zu zahlen
zu schauen was hilft an welcher Stelle
wenn wir auf das Gas schauen dann hilft
Atom nur ganz ganz ganz wenig da haben
wir andere Mitte mit denen wir Gas in
der Verstromung ersetzen können das sind
zum Beispiel die Kohlekraftwerke das ist
für mich als klimaschützerin kein
einfacher Schritt die wirken aber besser
das ist tatsächlich jetzt gerade auch
eine Frage der europäischen Solidarität
eine andere Frage ist die der Strom
versorgen bei der Stromversorgung habt
ihr nach jetzigen Stand mit Blick auf
Herbst und Winter eine gesicherte Lage
wir testen jetzt noch mal weil es
natürlich unsere Aufgabe ist uns
dauerhaft die Fakten anzuschauen und
dann anhand dieser Fakten zu entscheiden
was jetzt aber in ihre vorherigen Frage
so ein bisschen durchgedrungen war war
ja brauchen wir das dauerhaft und die
stromversorgungssicher zu starten wie es
für die Nase wäre für eine Situation zum
Beispiel bis 2024 die ja auch Herr
Habeck als den Zeitraum beschreibt also
bis 2024 zum Winter bräuchte man
irgendeine Lösung aber das wäre ja
tatsächlich dann der Wiedereinstieg in
die Atomkraft von der wir uns glaube ich
aus guten Gründen alle gemeinsam diese
Gesellschaft verabschiedet haben und in
den nächsten Jahren haben wir einen
anderen Weg haben wir einen besseren Weg
und das sind die erneuerbaren Energien
und da muss ich schon mal sagen dass
diese Debatte natürlich gerade teilweise
auch ein bisschen außer Proportion
gezogen wird von denen die in den
letzten 16 Jahren im Bund in Bayern zum
Beispiel Markus Söder genau beim Ausbau
dieser erneuerbar Energien versagt haben
dass die jetzt am lautesten nach Atom
schreien das ist ein bisschen so dass
man da den Bürgern auch etwas fanden die
Augen schiebt indem man sagt macht euch
keine Sorgen wir machen diesen einen
Schritt und dann wird alles gut und sich
vor den Debatten rund ums Energie sparen
um die Effizienz wegdrückt ich erwarte
zum Beispiel von einem Markus Schöder
ich erwarte eigentlich von allen die uns
in diesem Lage gebracht haben dass sie
endlich Teil einer Lösung werden lassen
Sie uns noch mal bei den Grünen bleiben
denn sie sind ja heute zu Gast bei mir
warum wollen sie eigentlich lieber in
Kauf nehmen dass sie jetzt länger CO2 in
die Luft pusten durch durch
Gaskraftwerke durch Kohlekraftwerke die
sie wieder anwerfen müssen als einmal an
ihrem Grundsatz zu rütteln die AKW jetzt
dicht zu machen ich muss anders sagen
mir geht es hier nicht um die Grundsätze
der Grünen und mir geht es hier nicht um
die Gründungsgeschichte der Grünen
sondern mir geht es ganz konkret um die
Versorgungslage im Herbst im Winter und
mir geht es um die Sicherheit in diesem
Land und da werden wir anhand der Fakten
und tun das schon jetzt immer wieder
abwägen aber ich habe es ja schon mal
gesagt wenn man schaut wo gerade Gas in
der Verstromung einge gestürzt dann sind
das ca 20 Prozent ein Großteil davon
wird einer Kraft wärmekoppelung
eingesetzt und kann da gar nicht ersetzt
werden deshalb auch Forderungen wie sie
heute mal von Christian Lindner kam dass
man jetzt sozusagen Gas komplett aus der
Verstromung rausziehen würde das würde
unabhängig Weil es gar nicht ersetzt
werden kann zu Blackouts führen und in
dem kleinen Teil wo dann das an noch
anders verwendet wird da wird es vor
allem in der Spitzenlast verwendet und
da brauchen wir flexibel einsetzbare
aber was wir ja tun ich glaube das macht
grüne Politik in dieser Zeit aus wenn
wir jetzt sagen die Kohle wird ein
bisschen länger eingesetzt müssen wir
auf der anderen Seite so viel schneller
werden bei der Reduktion von CO2 beim
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien dass
wir unsere Ziele 80% erneuerbare
Energien bis 2030 einhalten sie haben da
viel zu erklären die Gesellschaft hören
wir es jetzt sieht es in Umfragen
momentan eher anders man hat in der
Debatte manchmal das Gefühl dass sie
sich schon an einem grünen Grundsatz
festhalten vielleicht liegt es auch
daran dass sie einige andere grüne
Grundsätze schon kippen mussten in der
Regierungszeit teilt bevor sie in die
Regierung eingetreten sind mein Kollege
Thomas Reichert fasst das mal in 60
Sekunden zusammen
nach 16 Jahren in der Opposition waren
die Grünen zu vielen Bereit um endlich
wieder zu regieren es kam eine Ernte wie
hoch der Preis dafür sein würde
es begann mit dem Tempolimit das schon
gleich zu Beginn geopfert wurde um die
FDP ins Boot zu holen es folgte ein
offenes Türchen für die Zukunft des
verbrennermotors ein 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen nur fürs Militär nicht
für zivile Projekte
Laufzeitverlängerung für Kohlekraftwerke
ihre Stimme entscheidet über die letzte
Regierung die aktiv Einfluss auf die
Klimakrise nehmen kann das war die
Warnung und das grüne versprechen doch
in der Regierung mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine werden grüne Ziele abgeschliffen
zermahlen
die grüne Macht sitzt jetzt in
Ministerien macht Kompromisse
womöglich sogar bei der Atomkraft die
Parteivorsitzenden spielen zweite Geige
müssen die Partei bei der Stange halten
nur wie lange können Sie das noch
Frau lang die Partei zusammenzuhalten
das ist ihre Aufgabe als
co-parteivorsitzende und wir hören jetzt
schon erste Stimmen die zeigen wie
schwierig das vielleicht für sie werden
wird weil sie eben einen Spagat machen
müssen dabei der Realpolitik und den
Grundsätzen Hans Christian Ströbele
Urgestein ihres linken grünen Flügels
hat sich jetzt mit einem Tweet zu Wort
gemeldet den man anmerkt dass ihnen
graust davor wenn er auf ihre Politik
schaut er redet über die schweren Waffen
über die sie jetzt reden obwohl sie mal
als Friedenspartei auch gestartet sind
er sagt Atomausstieg wird jetzt
diskutiert und er schreibt dort wann
kippt die nächste Säule bloß nicht warum
muss da in 83-jähriger aus ihrer Partei
kommen um sie an grüne Grundsätze zu
erinnern ich erinnere mich sehr gut an
grüne grundsätzlich will man ein
Beispiel dafür nennen wir haben vor
zweieinhalb Jahren Grundsatzprogramm
beschlossen mit der gesamten Partei und
dieses Grundsatzprogramm das startet mit
einem Satz und das ist im Mittelpunkt
unserer Politik steht der Mensch in
seiner Würde und Freiheit und natürlich
fragt man sich in einer Situation
wo wir gestartet sind in die Regierung
mit nach 16 Jahren können wir endlich
das was wir in der Opposition immer nur
gefordert haben in der Realität umsetzen
und dann kommt ein Krieg und dann
verändert sich diese Realität und ja das
bedeutet für mich auch wenn man
verantwortungsvolle Politik macht dass
man dann schaut wie können diese
Grundsätze in dieser Realität
ausgestaltet werden und ich sag's mal
für mich persönlich wenn ich sage der
Mensch in seiner Würde und Freiheit
steht im Mittelpunkt zur Politik als
eine menschenrechtspartei bin dann heißt
das für mich auch dass wenn die
Menschenrechte von Menschen der Ukraine
dem Erdboden gleichgemacht werden soll
wenn ein Kriegsverbrecher Vladimir Putin
die internationale Friedensordnung
angreift die Freiheit von Millionen von
Menschen gefährdet dann heißt das dass
ich die Ukraine unterstütze auch mit
Waffen jetzt merkt man in ihrer Partei
dass einige sagen das muss doch aber
auch gehen während man auch Kritik übt
an dem was an der Parteispitze und im
Kabinett passiert Winfried Hermann
grüner Minister in Baden-Württemberg der
hat sich auch zu Wort gemeldet und hat
gesagt es wird mittlerweile viel zu
wenig diskutiert in der Partei und es
gibt zu wenig Kritik setzen Sie
vielleicht zu viel nach außen auf
Koalitionsfrieden und Harmonie müssten
sie nicht auch das was sie machen trotz
allem kritisch besprechen wir besprechen
vieles kritisch ich glaube wenn es in
der grünen Partei keine Diskussionen
mehr geben würde wäre es nicht die Grüne
Partei das Papier von Winne Herrmann mit
dem ich inhaltlich an keiner Stelle
übereinstimme ist das beste Beispiel
dafür dass wir natürlich die Debatten
führen und trotzdem erlebe ich eine sehr
geschlossene Partei wir haben einen
kleinen Parteitag gehabt wo wir zum
Beispiel die Waffenlieferungen
abgestimmt haben weil glaube ich auch
die Mitglieder unserer Partei sehen wie
gefragt unsere Grundwerte Klimaschutz
erneuerbare Energien Unabhängigkeit von
fossilen aber auch Menschenrechte in
dieser Situation sind wie schwierig es
ist sie umzusetzen und dass wir trotzdem
bereit sind diese schwierigen Schritte
zu gehen ehrlich gesagt würde ich mir
das manchmal auch ein bisschen von den
anderen Koalitionspartnern wünschen dass
man vielleicht bereit ist den ein oder
anderen zurückzulassen über den ein oder
anderen Schatten zu springen und das
bedeutet dann schon Verantwortung in der
Krisenzeit die Friedenspolitik ist aber
nicht das einzige was bei ihnen in der
Partei auch für Diskussionen sorgt sie
haben gerade gesagt sie das sind wir
sehr geschlossen wenn man mal in den
Wahlkreis von Robert Habeck schaut da
ist gerade der Kreisvorsitzende
zurückgetreten weil er sagt die
Windkraft Energie die Robert Habeck
dabei macht die Beschleunigung des Baus
von Windrädern das zerstört grüne
Umweltpolitik und Schutz von Diversität
der letzten Jahrzehnte ist das da nicht
ihre Aufgabe auch so einer Kritik eine
Stimme zu geben statt hier zu sitzen und
zu sagen wir sind alle ganz geschlossen
aber die Stimme gibt es doch gerade sie
haben die ja gerade formuliert aber
natürlich habe ich als Parteivorsitzende
auch die Aufgabe einen Kurs zu
formulieren für die Partei und für mich
heißt diese Kurs bei dem Beispiel dass
sie gerade angesprochen haben wir müssen
unfassbar schnell werden beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energie wir haben ja noch
mal in diesem Monaten gerade gesehen das
ist nicht nur eine Frage von Klimaschutz
das ist eine Frage von bezahlbaren
Preisen das ist eine Frage von
Sicherheit und von geopolitische
Unabhängigkeit müssen sie da Diversität
opfern sondern dass der Kreisvorsitzende
dort sagt nein genau das tun wir eben
nicht sondern wir gucken dass wir jetzt
in den Verfahren schneller werden und
dass wir aber auf der anderen Seite ein
Ausgleich schaffen beide Artenvielfalt
wenn wir über Go2 areas für die
Windkraft sprechen dann sprechen wir
gleichzeitig darum wie können wir mehr
Flächen für die Artenvielfalt biodi
Biodiversität zur Verfügung stellen denn
diese Widerspruch das ist ein komplett
falscher es ist klar abendvielfalt wird
es in Zukunft nur mit Klimaschutz geben
aber auch Klimaschutz funktioniert nur
mit Biodiversität das müssen wir
zusammenbringen und ja das heißt
natürlich auch als in der Regierung mal
Zielkonflikte aushalten zu können und
dann aber Lösungen zu finden die beiden
am nächsten kommen und ich glaube das
schaffen wir gerade mit der Windkraft
eigentlich sehr gut Zielkonflikte ist
ein gutes Stichwort sie haben ja gerade
ihre Koalitionspartner auch schon
angesprochen und gesagt die könnten sich
vielleicht auch in der ein oder anderen
Stelle etwas mehr bewegen denn
tatsächlich werden die Grünen ja an
vielen Stellen ausge bzw
beißen auf Granit wenn es um ihre
Grundsätze gibt geht Stichwort zum
Beispiel Schuldenbremse da sind sie da
sind sie gesprächsbereit und sagen zur
Not müsste man die eben auch Opfern da
sagt Herr Lindner ganz klar nein bei den
Waffenlieferungen da bremst herr Scholz
die aus nach ihrem Gefühl da hatte sich
Kathrin Göring-Eckardt jetzt gerade erst
zu Wort gemeldet und auch im sozialen
finden Sie in der Ampel relativ wenig
Gehör sie haben zuerst eine
übergewinnsteuer gefordert um die Kosten
in der Krise zu verteilen jetzt sagen
sie als grüne ja zu der gasumlage die
dazu führt dass die Energieversorger die
Mehrkosten dieser Krise auf die
Verbraucher umwälzen können wie sozial
ist das denn
zur gasumlage erstmal bei der Gasanlage
geht es nicht darum Profite von
irgendwelchen Unternehmen abzusichern
sondern es geht darum die
Versorgungslage für den Herbst und für
den Winter mit dem Gas also für die
einzelnen Endverbraucher aber auch zum
Beispiel für mittelständische
Kleinunternehmen sicherzustellen
Kosten obendrauf für den Verbraucher es
ist so dass wir bestimmte
systemrelevante Unternehmen haben in
diesem Bereich wenn die Pleite gehen
würden dann würden tatsächlich die
Stadtwerke zum Beispiel nicht mehr
beliefert werden können das heißt wir
hätten tatsächlich eine Versorgungslücke
das kann niemand wollen das hat machen
wir jetzt diese gasumlage dass wir in
einen Punkt gekommen sind wo wir uns so
abhängig gemacht werden dass es
notwendig ist das war ein riesen Fehler
den Fehler müssen wir jetzt ausbaden und
jetzt haben sie die Situation dass ein
Konzern wie RWE sagt wir machen 1,5
Milliarden Überschuss auch durch diese
teuren Gaspreise und zugleich müssen die
Menschen eben die gasumlage Zahlen wie
kann denn das sein genau und deshalb ist
für mich auch so wichtig wenn wir jetzt
eine gasumlage machen dann müssen
gleichzeitig weitere Entlastungen kommen
also noch in diesem Jahr in diesem
Herbst müssen wir Entlastung auf dem Weg
bringen die gerade Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen natürlich Menschen die zum
Beispiel Hartz4 leben aber auch die die
knapp darüber sind ein geringes
Einkommen haben die nichts ansparen
konnten den großen Teil ihres Geldes für
Lebensmittel für Wohnen für heizen
ausgeben die müssen wir Masken und zu
Finanzierung haben sie ja schon ein
Beispiel genannt die übergewinnsteuer
wir sehen jetzt das Unternehmen wie
Shell ein explodierenden Gewinn gemacht
haben wir reden hier nicht über kluge
Investitionsentscheidungen bisschen mehr
gewinnen sondern wir reden über Gewinne
die sich selbst Energieunternehmen nicht
mehr im vorstellen können in der
Vergangenheit dann machen wir doch jetzt
eine übergewinnsteuer damit finanzieren
wir Entlastungen und weil es ja manche
Argumente gibt von die übergewinnsteuer
das geht alles gar nicht auch von
unserem Koalitionspartner wir sehen in
Spanien in UK wir sind vielen anderen
Ländern funktioniert und das ist
wirklich mal ein Punkt wo ich sagen
würde Gerechtigkeit first Bedenken
Zecken sie haben dieses Argument schon
sehr oft gebracht aber Herr Lindner
bleibt ganz standhaft und sagt nein am
Ende gibt der Kanzler den Ausschlag bei
solchen Fragen wann wünschen sie sich
eigentlich von ihm eine Unterstützung
zum Beispiel für so eine solche Position
macht er da genug ich glaube dass wir
den Herbst gemeinsam nutzen werden um
auch genau solche Dinge auf den Weg zu
bringen denn uns ist allen klar putin
will unsere Gesellschaft Spalten indem
er jetzt die Gaspreise damit spielt das
immer wieder hoch und runter macht und
wenn wir uns nicht spalten lassen und
ich glaube das muss unsere Aufgabe
bezahlen Herr Lindner sagt nein sie
bekommen keine weiteren entlassen dann
geht es darum den sozialen Zusammenhalt
und ja ich erwarte dass ihm das vorher
gesagt ich glaube ein sehr vielen
Stellen können wir Grüne gerade genau
auch grüne Grundsätze zum Beispiel
erneuerbaren Energien umsetzen aber
natürlich ist es eine schwierige
Ausgangslage auch für eine FDP ist das
eine schwierige Ausgangslage wenn wir
als Grüne mit Klimaschutz in die
Regierung gegangen sind jetzt
Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen lassen
desto schwierig wenn man als FDP an
Finanzministerium übernimmt und dann die
Realität die Schuldenbremse immer mehr
in Frage stellt dann ist das schwierig
aber ich glaube da müssen dann alle
bereit sein mal über ihren Schatten zu
springen das erwarte ich auch vom
Koalitionspartner ich glaube das
erwarten auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in diesem Land das eine Regierung dieser
Situation Verantwortung übernimmt es
gibt unterschiedliche Arten wie wir
weitere soziale Entlastungen finanzieren
können die Schuldenbremse haben sie
genannt die übergewinnsteuer aber am
Ende muss eine davon umgesetzt werden
wenn wir dürfen die Menschen mit diesen
steigenden Kosten nicht alle lassen und
wir werden die Menschen auch nicht
alleine lassen da werden Ihnen noch
Debatten ins Haus stehen auch in der
Koalition bei diesen unterschiedlichen
Positionen die haben sie jetzt markiert
ich danke Ihnen erst einmal hier für das
Gespräch herzlichen Dank dankeschön
das war das sommerinterview mit der
ko-vorsitzenden der Grünen in der
kommenden Woche treffe ich Alice Weidel
die kurvorsitzende der AFD zum Gespräch
ihnen herzlichen Dank fürs zuschauen und
einen schönen Abend
[Musik]